[Music]
you may have noticed one online trend
during the pandemic along with sharing
pictures of pets many people are showing
off their favorite house plants too
whether it was a new hobby during
downtime or a way to brighten up that
work from home office one study found
that almost two-thirds of americans have
added plants to their collection during
the pandemic and in dallas one
plant-loving entrepreneurs come up with
a whole new place to do just that
rodney hawkins has the story
you can like push some of it back you
know to get that view when you look at
it you know what i'm saying yeah it's
all about the aesthetics
nature is on full display at the first
ever plant lounge owned and operated by
anthony robinson and fill yours up
because if not your plan's gonna be sunk
down well you got a cigar lounge you got
a hookah lounge but there's no plant
lounge
and what is a plant lounge i mean you
can come in here and work watch tv
listen to music
sit on the sofa i just wanted to create
an environment where you didn't feel
that you had to come in buy your plant
buy whatever you bought and leave i
wanted people to be able to feel at home
welcome and come in and just relax if
they needed to
robinson opened energy gardens last
spring after his plant cells exploded
during the pandemic the self-described
plant artist creates elaborate
terrariums and frame moss walls after
the pandemic happened all my markets
shut down i didn't know what i was going
to do delivered food for a few days like
no you know i can deliver plants
went home posted a few online
it went crazy i said this is what i'm
going to do and it never stopped there's
a fast growing market for house plants
with 37 million people gardening indoors
in 2020 up from 33 million in 2019.
everybody wants plants and that's
beautiful is it just a fad
no no that's not a fad because you have
plants they won't expire i mean you have
some of these plants for 20 and 30 years
you'll be passing them down to your
family members
and while this is robinson's calling it
wasn't always his day job
i had a job that i just really didn't
like i didn't like it so you know
instead of going to work sad on monday
and happy on friday doing that for the
next 20 or 30 years said well let me
plan out let me see what i need to do
let me do the markets and do the
different festivals for a year let me
see if i can live off of that i had my
corporate job did that from eight to
five got off work spent time with my
kids
did my plant projects and things at
night and sold them on the weekends
it took him more than six years to
cultivate his plant side hustle into a
brick and mortar business voila in the
trendy dallas neighborhood called deep
ella
what do people say when they see you are
out here selling plants and so invested
in nature it's kind of normal number
when i started there was nobody in this
industry that looked like me
nobody so i would go to my wholesale
nurseries or wholesale places to buy
pots a lot of them thought i was an
employee as time has changed i mean i'm
i'm the guy i'll be standing outside
sometimes people drive by hey energy
gardens one of robinson's loyal
customers
is 32 year old jesse washington plants
have become so popular during the
pandemic did you buy a lot of yours
during the pandemic last year i think i
bought about two or three two three big
ones i bought a big snake plant i bought
a big ponytail palm
and
the typewriter so you saying that out
loud did you think you were going to be
this plant person that has six or seven
plants no not not originally but you get
compliments on them makes the space
better so he makes designs and the way
he arranges them the way he shoots them
they're always so fresh like it makes
you want to you want to get them
robinson's arrangements are so popular
he sells out sip and plant parties today
we're going to build an arrangement with
about three to four succulents he showed
me how to make my own low maintenance
arrangement it's an easy process that
starts with potting soil grab it fill it
all the way up to the top and i'll help
you i'm getting back to my uh my my kids
side right yeah then come a few
succulents just grab it like that oh so
we're gonna dust it off yeah yeah you
can you can knock off a little bit of
the soil like so
and last but not least a decorative
layer put a few
of the of the rocks around i'll let you
do that side oh yeah just put a few
around there
there we go
two shot glasses purple okay cause i was
like i don't even know what that means
when you say two ounces two shot glasses
per plant every three to four weeks and
as far as light goes indirect sunlight
right or like led light or fluorescent
lights the results were something
robinson says everyone can do even if
you don't have a green thumb you know a
lot of people think they can't keep
plants alive they say well i have a
black thumb i'm like well me too i got
two of them i do just fine have you seen
it transform people's lives especially
now that so many people are working from
home to just have a few plants or that
one plant you speak of yeah
when you have live plants you get that
visual and you get that feeling of that
living energy and that's what i sell i
sell plants but i'm selling that feeling
robinson hopes to share this energy
from the garden with everyone he can
for cbs saturday morning rodney hawkins
dallas texas
um
that's something make somebody get some
plans yeah i do kill them but now i'm
inspired i will try not to anymore